big news in my television business here
my old bosses NBC NBC said it might
offer it's streaming service for free if
you watch ads that's what they said
NBC simply got the idea from what we've
been doing for the last 70 years
we're gonna go streaming with ads the
same thing and we'll show it to a
television here's a weird story in
Arkansas one of Jim Bob and Michelle
Duggar 'he's 19 children is running for
political office yeah he's running on
one issue birth control piece yeah my
life is a living hell
he said there's too many Me's cool story
at a NASA NASA has sent several cases of
Bordeaux wine into space yeah yeah
NASA described the launch as zesty and
unpretentious
that got what it deserves
turns out you people are great
connoisseurs of jokes you tasted the
joke and you spit it out we should have
jokes spit buckets right next to
everyone on the crowd they just no I
don't think so and spit it out new study
this is true a new study came out and it
reveals that most people lie when they
meet someone they want to have sex with
now which explains why a woman has never
lied to me
you